[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar a practical guide to creating
digital ready slides
i am marie stone of labrutz and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by leica biosystems
to learn more visit
leicabiosystems.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
dr olga colgan global brand strategy
director leica systems olga you may now
begin your presentation
thank you for the introductions and
hello and thank you to everybody who has
joined today
and what i would like to bring us
through today is to introduce the
concept of digital ready slides what
exactly do we mean by that what are the
attributes associated with it and also
to provide some practical guidelines and
pragmatic tips on how best to create
digital ready slides
as we look at digital ready slides and
creating digital ready slides one of the
questions i often get asked is well why
now
and to do this maybe we take a little
bit of a step back
and look at when artificial intelligence
kind of first became recognized and this
was back in the 1950s where the the term
artificial intelligence was first coined
by john mccarthy adele and looking at a
branch of machine learning where a
computer could emulate
what a human may do in the the same
situation
and then we jump forward to kind of the
last two decades
and looking at the widespread adoption
of digital pathology across a number of
use cases whether that's in
research or clinical type applications
i'm moving exclusively away from the
microscope and starting to leverage
digital pathology and on-screen review
of slides
and it's kind of the convergence of
these two
that are leading us to digital ready
slides
but even then the why now question still
exists and i refer to this sometimes as
the perfect storm
and we're now at a stage where the
maturity of digital pathology technology
is at that stage where it is suitable
for
true high throughput routine usage
you also have acceptance of the usage of
digital
pathology by a number of the governing
bodies and regulatory bodies
in different regions across the world
we've also seen massive developments in
the infrastructure and i.t capabilities
that are available both looking at disk
speeds
the widespread availability of internet
connectivity and wi-fi
and also a huge body of evidence and
proof of the value of the utilization of
digital pathology
and really that puts us in a position
where now we're starting to see as well
the development of artificial
intelligence-based tools
for usage with digital pathology
and really the input to those
to any development of an artificial
intelligence based tool for pathology is
going to be based on those digital
pathology slides
and really that gives the whole
requirement and the need
for having digital ready slides
so there are some key features and that
digital ready slides should exhibit
and you can see them here on screen
the first is that these will scan
automatically
and really this is to minimize the user
intervention
and the idea here being that as you
start using these routinely for high
throughput widespread scanning
you don't want to be burning
30 seconds or a minute on every slide
because the hands-on time for that just
becomes
paralyzing the other piece is that you
really want to make sure you capture all
tissue that's on the side
and this would include any small
fragments of tissue if there's faintly
stained tissue in particular in the the
case if you may have some ihc staining
and there's faint expression in a
fragment of tissue you really want to
make sure that that's still captured or
low cellular density tissue as well
which can sometimes be problematic so
you want to make sure that all that
tissue is captured on the slide
but then also you want to make sure that
it's done with the smallest possible
scan area
and ideally in one focal plane
and really where this comes to is you
could capture the whole slide
region for every single slide but you're
going to capture an awful lot of white
space
at usually high resolution scanning and
that is going to firstly take longer to
scan and secondly you're going to have
the larger file size and then storage
requirements that are unnecessary so
these two pieces to together where you
want to capture all the tissue but you
want to do it in the smallest possible
area and again if possible in one focal
plane because as you capture these
digital pathology slides they can be
very large depending on the
magnification that you're using
depending on the the size of the piece
of tissue that you're capturing
but these are in the range of anywhere
between 250 megabytes to a gigabyte in
size give or take
every time you capture a z-stack
you're capturing another image so you're
multiplying then the file size
across the slide so ideally for routine
usage if you can capture at a single
focal plane that's going to be
advantageous both from a scan time and a
file size perspective
the final piece
in the the key features or the
attributes of digital ready slides is to
automate the data flow
and again this is with a view to
minimizing hands on time not sitting
there doing data entry but of also to
avoid manual data entry and associated
error risks
as we look at bringing digital pathology
into a laboratory
it's not as simple as just putting a
scanner in after the cover slipping
stage
um and taking off from them we really
need to look holistically at the
complete workflow that end-to-end
workflow within the lab and all the
different steps in that tissue
preparation stage that will actually
impact your final slide and how do we
optimize each of these steps to create
these digital ready slides
and so for this i'm going to start at
embedding and this predominantly
pertains to when you're embedding
multiple tissues in the one block and
such as needle core biopsies for
instance
and the first piece is to cluster the
samples together
and that this follows some of the the
best practice that you would have
typically anywhere at embedding but the
idea being and you can see it clearly
and the cluster samples in the one on
the left samples are quite spread out
so what this is going to do
is from a scanning perspective you're
going to have a larger scan area
there so that's going to take longer to
scan
and it's also going to lead to a larger
file size
this and then the version on the right
shows you if you just put those a little
closer together still with sufficient
space so that they don't overlap during
sectioning and there's
limited risk that that would happen but
this is going to give you probably about
half the the scan region and again
that's going to make you twice as fast
and half the the file size
the other piece when you're you're
clustering your samples is all to align
them in the the same direction
and where this also gives an advantage
depending on the scanner that you're
using or the type of focusing mechanism
that it uses
if you can align your samples so
that the focusing method or the scanning
of your slides follows the direction of
your tissue
you have a much higher chance that all
of your tissue will be in focus
and that's because your scanner isn't
going to jump from tissue into white
space into tissue
and kind of mapping that micro
topography of the environment
then as we move on from embedding and
into to microtomy um there is a massive
importance of best practice
and some of these things aren't
exclusive to to digital pathology or
digital ready slides however they can be
exaggerated when you move into a digital
environment
and again if you look at something like
tears
they're
annoying and bothersome when you're
reviewing under a microscope
however when you start to utilize
digital pathology this can cause the
focusing again depending on the type of
scanner that you're using it can cause
the focusing to to jump out of focus
where in that white space it's trying to
detect tissue and maybe it'll detect a
fragment that's at a different level in
the micro topography and then cause them
out of focus region
the very same is true for folds
um within tissue and even looking at the
example that we have here that tissue is
going to be two three maybe four times
deeper in this folded region that you
can see
and again that's going to lead to
out-of-focus regions
or the necessity to then acquire in
z-stacks
as we we move across and i look at
contamination and this is an example of
the fungal contamination within the
water bath and from not changing the
water frequently enough
and these little flecks of debris then
that appear on the slide
can be recognized by your scanner as
faintly stained tissue
or
potentially low density tissue and again
that's going to lead to a much greater
region of interest being selected and
scanned
for the the slide leading to those
against slower scan times and larger
file sizes
and the same
thing is true with chatter
in
in your sides or in your tissue very
similar to the the tears or the folds
which is all about that focusing
mechanism and about being able to map
that micro topography within your slides
so in addition to all of those kind of
standard best practice pieces at
microtomy
some considerations where you may need
to vary your practice when you start
looking at introducing digital pathology
is the section thickness and quite often
this can be a little bit thinner than
the sections that are typically used so
it's typically somewhere in the region
of three to four microns tends to be
ideal
for digital pathology enabling you to
scan in a single focal plane
and if we have a look at how this works
and you can see a kind of an overview
here of an objective lens very typical
as to what you would see inside most
scanners
and you'll have your your layer of
optimal focus and then you'll have a
depth of field
if you have thin sections and they will
have that micro topography and
variability along with the surface of
the tissue
but if all of your tissue
falls within that depth of field and we
can map according to it
then there's a high chance that you will
be able to capture all of your tissue in
focus in a single focal plane pass
however if your sample is thicker then
you may find there are areas where you
cannot capture at a single focal plane
and then that's going to push you to a
situation where you're going to need to
employ z stacking
or have out of focus regions
neither of which are optimized when
you're looking to do high throughput
routine scanning
the other piece to take into
consideration when you look at section
thickness is the impact of thickness on
staining
and in the example here i'm looking at
ihc staining interpretation and it is
documented in the literature and
peer-reviewed publications on showing
that section thickness
affects our interpretation of ihc
staining whether that is done manually
or whether that's done using automated
analysis techniques
and i think this even becomes more
important as we start looking at either
manual sharing of slides a manual review
on screen with digital pathology
where you could be under calling or over
calling your ihc staining based on the
section thickness
or indeed as we look at the further
development of tools utilizing and
leveraging ai
and that standardization
of your section thickness becomes even
more and more important
moving on but still at the microtomy is
your tissue placement so when you're
actually floating your sections you've
got nice ribbons you're floating your
sections and the placement on the slide
best rule of thumb is to place centrally
but again this is even more exaggerated
when you look at digital pathology
because most scanners will have a no
scan zone
um towards the edges of the slide and
this no scan zone may even overlap with
the edges of the coverslip again it
varies model to model and manufacturer
to manufacturer so it's important to
know for the scanner that you're looking
to use within your laboratory
what are the the borders for the actual
scan region and to make sure that all of
your tissue is within that scan region
or that scannable region um on the the
slide and to make sure that you don't
have situations like they're shown on
the left of the slide here where again
best practice you don't have fragments
of tissue outside of this cover slip
area
all of these things if you
if you have your tissue misplaced on the
slide they can impact your tissue
detection your tissue focusing and also
the ability to actually capture all of
that tissue in your digital slide
moving on then away from across me but
onto the slide labeling and the first
piece i'd like to touch on here is in
relation to automatic slide
identification
and i've said it previously but the rule
of thumb that i go by here is if you're
looking to scan
any more than a hundred slides daily
you really will need to to look at
barcoding your slides
um
digital pathology images are are so
large they do require specialized image
management and viewing software
and typically then you you need to
associate your metadata
with those slides so
you know where is that site from which
case or animal or study is it related to
and that's where integrating with your
laboratory data system whether that's
your your list or your limbs becomes
active loosely integral
into having an end-to-end solution for
your digital pathology and that what
that will allow you to do is based on
your barcodes
automate the association of your slide
data and your whole slide images and and
aggregate those cases or those studies
together
so to move from a situation where you
are
manually slide sorting
into the appropriate groups or cases
to something that can then be truly
automated and this is one of the areas
where bringing digital pathology into a
laboratory can add some extra steps to
the lab but it can also help alleviate
some of those traditional steps such as
the the case sorting which can be done
automatically so there are
some
workflow benefits that can be realized
there as well
the other piece about using barcodes or
your slide labeling comes from
minimizing your your data error risk
um and nobody wants error within their
databases
so looking firstly at the manual
workflow
and the the slides here are supposed to
represent hand written slides
and for those of you with a very keen
eye
you may notice that the slide at the
back says b46h
and the one at the front is b46hs0
or is it a zero or is it an o
it's very difficult to tell and often
impossible to distinguish with
handwriting
as we move along then
this is clearly an area where you have
risk
there's very much risk of
you know
handwritten errors but also interpreting
that handwriting reading somebody else's
handwriting
can always be problematic and it's also
very time consuming and compared to
generating slide labels automatically
it doesn't really impact too much at the
scanning stage
but the next area then where it comes is
once you have your slide scanned
how are you going to create in a manual
workflow where you have handwritten
slides you're going to manually have to
create that association between your
digital slide coming off your scanner
and your your database whatever format
that might be in
and this requires significant data entry
and with any data entry it's going to be
time consuming and take up it's another
job to be done manually
and it's also going to be inherently
prone to keystroke errors
that ultimately those two pieces
together
then lead to potential errors within
that final aggregated slide and data set
that you have
however if we look at the barcoded
workflow
you have the ability to have human
readable and barcoded
um labels as the one label
you eliminate that error that you may
have with handwritten or transcription
errors
and then leveraging that integration
pathway with the existing information
management systems you can be assured
then that the right slide is being
associated with the correct data within
your information management system and
that aggregation is being done
automatically
so by moving to to this type of scenario
you really are going to limit your risk
and eliminate some of those manual
workflow steps within the the process
that overall give you greater confidence
and security in what you're actually
viewing digitally on screen
or indeed leveraging for
ai or automated image analysis
development
when it actually comes to the the slide
labeling there are some best practices
to consider
with this things to do and things to
avoid
so if you have multiple overlapping
labels
you can run into to some difficulties or
come up against some challenges
the first is that you may exceed the
slide thickness tolerance
and again this is going to be very
scanner dependent um and looking at how
different scanners and different models
move the slide
from whatever kind of either slide tray
or slide carrier it has and puts it in
under that objective for high resolution
scanning and there are a number of
different methodologies involved whether
it's a push pull mechanism on the slides
some scanners have little grabbers where
they they pick up the slides and move
them
others put them into little clip based
slide trays
um for for moving into the that kind of
under the objective for the high
resolution scanning
all of them though have a tolerance no
matter which mechanism is employed each
of them will have a thought tolerance to
the slide size and the slide thickness
and if you exceed this you run the risk
where slides can get jammed
the um
which is kind of the
easiest one to resolve it in a lot of
cases but still jammed slides mean it's
unscheduled downtime you're going to
have to remove them similarly to the way
you'd remove a paper jam in a printer
and slides may not fit in the carriers
in the worst case scenario sites can get
stuck you may not be able to resolve it
you know on site you may need to call in
an engineer
or in worst case scenario slides could
get broken leaving obviously you're
going to lose that sample which is
not a good place to be in if this is a
rare or a sample where you can't go back
and cut from another block or i'm
potentially broken glass within your
scanner mechanism neither of which are
positive things
and the same is true for sticky
overhangs so trying to ensure that when
you place your slide label on your slide
that it is fully within the boundaries
of your glass slide because again
similarly sticky overhangs they can
stick the slides to the moving
mechanisms to trays and again can result
in all those problems we just discussed
with broken slides potentially broken
glass damage slides slides jammed in the
the mechanisms
so best practice is where possible
single slide label
within the the boundaries of the glass
slide
the next step in the process that i'd
like to speak to in relation to digital
ready slides is actually around the
staining
um and whether this is your h e staining
your standard routine staining
special stains ihc or other staining
modalities
moving from
reading slides on a microscope to
reading on screen is a paradigm shift
for the the reviewer whether that's a
pathologist or
um laboratory personnel or researchers
and
by standardizing your your staining
you're going to remove one of those
obstacles or
those pieces that need to be overcome as
you're you're moving towards on-screen
review
the other piece is that some of those
added advantages of digital pathology
such as the multi-slide review options
you can see it here on the the top right
hand side where you can pull multiple
slides onto screen
at the same time potentially cereal
sections
um from
the one piece of tissue or to compare
the the staining and the expression
profile
and between
different groups or different study
groups in a research situation
that is going to emphasize any staining
variation that you may have within your
tissue preparation
and you want to be able to have that
confidence
to say that the staining that you're
looking at is true staining
and that for instance in the example
that's shown here
that that is a variation in staining and
that the
tissue on the left hand side does have a
higher expression profile and that this
isn't to do with
manual variation in staining that i
didn't leave it to to bind as long as i
needed to
um and really it's that
ability of digital pathology to maybe
highlight and emphasize some of these
items
um
the other piece and you'll see it then
down on the h e slides towards the
bottom of the screen
these are actually serial sections
of the same tissue cut to the same
thickness and sent to different labs
asking them to just do their normal h e
staining on it
and what you'll see here is a massive
variation into the the color and the
intensity
of the staining of their their h e
and as you start looking at leveraging
digital pathology either for sharing
across multiple sites where you have
your tissue coming from different labs
and either into a centralized or
distributed review
that can highlight some of these
differences and really bring them to the
fore
and it also potentially has that impact
as you start looking at ai development
and
what's the variability in your input to
those training sets
and what impact does it actually have
then on the size of the training set
that you need and the performance of
your your ai tools
the next piece at the staining air stage
is to make sure that your slides are
free of any staining debris or artifacts
um and the the easiest and most simple
way to do this is to ensure that you
have the appropriate post stain washes
and what they will do is obviously
remove any residual stain if you've got
any streaks of stain across your slide
and sometimes you'll get those dab
clumps and in particular if you're doing
any kind of manual ihc work and or just
general debris
um
and again these pieces of debris
can be problematic on a number of
different levels when you start looking
at digital pathology and scanning those
slides and the first is that and in the
the situation of the slide on the top
here
where this piece of debris towards the
left-hand side
could be recognized as tissue and again
that's going to increase then the scan
area which is going to give you a bigger
file slide size and slower scanning and
that's going to give you slower
throughput overall and if this is a
recurring issue it will really start to
impact on that throughput of scanning
within your laboratory
and it can also lead to out-of-focus
regions again depending on the scanning
mechanism
of the the instrument that you're um
utilizing
it can cause it to recognize maybe the
debris as the tissue and set the kind of
gross focusing um similar to your your
course focus on a microscope that it
would be set there and then your actual
tissue of interest may be out of focus
and it can also lead to missed tissue
again if you had a situation where
you've got a big clump of dark debris
and then you've got some faintly stained
tissue and may recognize the debris as
the the tissue and scan that instead of
the the sample of interest
um and all of this can lead to numerous
problems as we've discussed
the last step then as we move on from
from staining is cover slipping and this
is the the last process before
either going into your microscopy
based review or before scanning
um
and i would say if you're really looking
to employ digital pathology and create
digital ready slides to give very strong
consideration to automated cover
slipping if it's not ready already
employed within your laboratory
and this is for a number of reasons
and the first is the elimination of
bubbles
and again bubbles are can be problematic
when focusing where they get recognized
as tissue
so if they are co-located with the
tissue similar to reviewing under a
microscope you may not be able to pull
that tissue into sharp focus
and because of the the bubble
if it is located away from the tissue
again this can be
um
identified as tissue and then captured
within the scan region
the other piece is no excess mounting
media
and this is quite similar in a lot of
ways to the the same situation that we
had with the the sticky labels on the
slide and that excess mounting media
has
two phases
when before it's fully cured and
hardened and it's in that sticky and
tacky um state it then runs the risk of
sticking to your your moving mechanisms
within the scanner whether that's a
slide tray or moving on to
your scanning stage for that high
resolution scanning
sticky slides are more likely to
get stuck in your your instrument and
lead to a number of problems and
jammed slides broken slides glass in
your your scanner um
the other pieces then
if that excess mounting media has
hardened
again you may have lumps of this hard
mounting media at the edges of your
slide which you're going to mean that
your side exceeds or could exceed the
tolerance of your scanner
and again leading to the the range of
problems
the other piece is to have clean dry
slides
not all scanners keep the slides in a
completely horizontal
um
position some of them will tip them
either at an angle or into a vertical
position in some situations
so if your slides aren't fully drying if
your cover slips aren't fully dry
and there is a risk that they will start
to slide off
and pull your tissue with them
the other piece is if you've been
handling the slides between cover
slipping
and scanning there's a risk of putting
debris or fingerprints or glove dust
on these slides
finally you need to make sure that your
cover slip is on straight and again this
is due to the tolerance that the
different scanners will have um in
relation to movement of the the slide or
the slide trays and
within the the scanner
so overall and i suppose to to summarize
as we look at digital ready slides or
digital pathology the the adoption of
digital pathology is such a
multi-faceted project and affects
multiple stakeholders within any
pathology department and as i mentioned
at the the top of the presentation it's
not simply just about adding a scanner
after cover slipping
and adding it to your workflow it really
affects the whole laboratory workflow
and requires careful consideration on
taking that holistic view
of slide creation to really generate
those optimized digital ready slides
so with that in mind that brings me to
the end of my presentation today and i
would be very happy to take any
questions that you may have
thank you very much
thank you olga for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started
our first question is
do these principles apply to fluorescent
slides
oh well that's um that's a great
question
i think yes and no would be my my answer
on that one i think there are some
elements in relation to your tissue
placement the cover slipping the slide
labeling
and some of the best practices
absolutely that would apply
um i think with fluorescent slides
often utilized more in the the research
and life science domains
um
and at times are can be thicker samples
so with fluorescence i think you need to
take into consideration um what
magnification you're looking at with
your scanner
um
and you know is it something that can be
done at a single focal plane or are you
going to a high resolution scan let's
say above 40x maybe a 60 or an 80 and
some of the fluorescent scanners on the
market will do
in which case you're going to have a
smaller depth of field so you may need
to look at employing the stacking and
with that
i think the other piece to consider with
fluorescent scanning is the number of
passes across the tissue as well
so you're not necessarily going to be
able to capture in a single path
and again depending on
the scanner that you would be using you
may need to look at your
your different excitation excitation and
emission
levels and the different filters and
each of those filter cubes may require a
separate pass across the tissue
and so maybe to summarize up
yes a lot of the the principles of
digital ready slides apply whether
you're looking at a bright field or a
fluorescence or
fish
um
but you may need to tweak some of them
to your own specific needs
all right thank you
next question
what about fixed sections or cytology
preparations how can these be handled
yeah another another great question and
i'm one that's a quite similar in a lot
of ways
and i think if your sections are
inherently thick
and
you don't have the option to cut thinner
sections because of what you're looking
at in your your tissue or your sample
then if they are inherently thick you
are going to have to consider z-stacking
and to be able to capture all of those
focal planes and to to kind of maximize
what you get out of that tissue or out
of that slide
um
similarly for cytology and and again
that the majority of scanners on the
market today are optimized for use with
tissue
and so if anybody is considering using
with cytology preparations
um i would always recommend firstly
check with the manufacturer and see if
the scanner is suitable for cytology
preparations
and then the second would be to
actually
when you get somebody in or when you're
looking at a demonstration of these
units make sure you're scanning your own
slides
um and
samples that are representative of your
your lab output and your kind of um
typical usage or typical slides that you
would create
um it's never any harm to throw in a
worst of worst
type preparation to see you know how
how the scanner can cope with the you
know
worst type of slide that maybe comes out
of your lab um but i think have standard
ones and test the scanner with your own
samples
all right thank you
next question
is color standardization really
important don't pathologists just
naturally adjust for differences in
staining such as h and e
yes i think um
that this is a very interesting one and
one that could be um lead us to hours of
debate around the topic
and
yes the the human eye and pathologists
and reviewers will
naturally kind of white balance or
adjust their eye for for changes in
staining and we're not as sensitive to
it when you're looking down a microscope
because you look at each of the slides
in individuality you're just looking at
one h e and then if the the next one
that you put
on your your microscope is you know five
or ten percent difference
in the staining you're probably not
going to observe that or kind of realize
it at that kind of point under the
microscope
however it's some of the the power of
digital pathology and being able to put
those slides side by side in a viewer
that really starts to highlight where
you will have differences or drift in
your staining
and really where this kind of has a
two-part play out to it
and the first is when you're looking at
a manual on-screen review
and utilizing digital pathology they say
that side by side can highlight
differences
also if you're receiving in slides from
multiple laboratory locations let's say
you're working in some kind of networked
environment with multiple labs
um
finishing in or um
sending slides in then that can
highlight differences in the the hme or
you know they're staining between the
labs
and then you have a situation as a
reviewer where you're looking at these
lines and going well are these
differences in the tissue or these
differences in the staining
and as i mentioned i think in the
presentation
moving from microscope review to
on-screen review is a complete paradigm
shift
um
so
the more barriers or
irregularities that we can remove and
the more we can move towards
standardization that makes that much
easier from a manual perspective
i said it's kind of a two-part one
though because the other where the other
point where this really comes into play
is as you start looking at the
development of automated analysis tools
or ai based tools
and
really then when you start looking at
color and color standardization
without color standardization or
staining standardization in your your
slides you're bringing another variable
into the the mix and it's not to say
that this can't be overcome but if the
opportunity is there as best practice to
standardize as much as possible
for that input into your ai training set
and development then you're just
removing another potential source of
error
i hope that covers the the question but
please feel free to pop another question
in the the q a box if that doesn't fully
answer what you were looking to cover
there
all right great thank you
our next question is
can the attributes of digital ready
slides be universally standardized and a
worldwide available digital slide
biobank perhaps in the manner of whole
genome sequence
be made for eventual worldwide universal
referencing
wow that's a good one and would be a
fantastic project
um
again this is a little bit of a depends
i think can the attributes of digital
ready slides be applied universally
theoretically yes um
but again with something like this it
depends if you are looking at doing
something
prospectively or retrospectively
so if these slides are already created
um then obviously you've very limited
input as to what you can do with them
and other than scan them in their
current state
you could of course look at a situation
where you're taking new sections from
blocks and creating slides from the
outset
and i think in that scenario then you
could
kind of almost have entry criteria with
your your slide submission sites
and that they would standardize to
you know a range of
attributes across the slides so i think
they may be dependent on
the actual study um and how it's going
to be done prospective or
retrospectively um and the capabilities
of the sites that would be feeding into
it
um i do know there's a project running
in the the uk
um between genomics england and the
national pathology imaging cooperative
who are looking at something like this
um i don't have it hand but i know there
was a press release on this in the last
couple of weeks and so that might be one
to look up if you're interested in this
topic
excellent thank you
our next question is
clustering samples does that mean we
need to limit the number of levels that
are placed on a slide
gi biopsies in our lab typically have
two levels with two sections of each
level on a slide so four total sections
on a slide
and the correct answer is no
you don't need to limit the number of
levels and that are placed on a slide
um and if this is a slide preparation
that is standard for your lab and that's
all right thank you
no i'm still here oh sorry sorry are you
cut out i'm sorry
no it was me it was my computer just did
something terribly funny there um
apologies but no you don't need to limit
of the the number of levels that are
placed on the slide i think what you
would need to do though is be really
careful
about microtumia and kind of floating
stage when you're putting your samples
on the slide to make sure that they are
not only inside the boundaries of your
coverslip but that they're also inside
the the boundaries of the scan region
for the scanner that you would be using
and as much as possible bring them close
together which and
kind of touched on is going to give you
a smaller scan area
and a smaller file size and faster
throughput overall
for your your scanners so
i wouldn't
i wouldn't recommend necessarily
changing away from some of the practices
on how tissue is presented
um but just are there steps that can be
done to optimize
um those processes
next question
can the system read slides i mean after
scanning the slide an h e stain slide
will the ai tell if the tissue is normal
or pathologic
um
again great question and this is really
where
we see an awful lot of research and
development and innovation around this
space and both with h e slides
um and then across a range of stains and
both for for clinical or research
applications
um
there's no
kind of silver bullet or magic app out
there
that is doing this and for some of the
products that have been released to
market already they're done on a
kind of subspecialty or tissue based
um
system at the moment as opposed to
you know any tissue on any slide in any
lab being put through it and saying you
know is it normal or is it a tumor um
but it's a
massively accelerating area at the
moment with so much focus and interest
um
there's a lot of indications that this
is the direction
that the technology is moving
great thank you
our next question is is there a
difference using glass and plastic tape
cover slips
i think i'll probably look at this in a
similar way to the the question about
cytology and fluorescence
um
which is check your slides out with the
scanner you're you're considering using
um
different scanners employ different
focus mechanisms and tissue detection
um mechanisms
so you need to ensure that
the the scanner will work with your
samples as they're created whether
that's using glass or plastic cover
slipping it's also going to depend on
the glass and the the tape
cover slips that you're you're looking
at using and the specific optical
properties
of those
and
and also maybe the the magnification
that you're looking to scan at um you
know there can be differences in the use
of glass and tape and at different
magnifications and before that the most
part they say
my recommendation would be
try it out with your your samples and
that the scanner you're interested in
and then if it doesn't work
consider the part that you would like to
change is it easier to
choose a different scanner
or is it easier to change your cover
slipping mechanism and maybe be
open to
multiple ways to solve that problem if
it occurs
all right thank you
next question
is there anything we can do to color
correct to have more consistency with
glass between slides
i'm not sure i fully understand that
question if we're looking at the
the actual glass color from a
almost background perspective or if it's
standardization of the the color with
the the slide so maybe i'll try and
address this in two different ways
and i think that the first is if it's
specifically on the color of the glass
sometimes these can have a slightly
green tint or other
and very slight colored tints to the
glass
um and then if you're looking to
standardize on that part
um i think
it'd be interesting to look at some of
the functionality within different
scanners that will white balance
and so detect a piece on the the slide
where there is no tissue or no sample
and
and look to to white balance on that so
effectively normalize on your your color
profile and in that way i think if the
question was more in relation to the the
consistency
of staining between slides
and i think with that then is
where possible avoid manual staining
where you're doing manual dilutions of
your stains
and look at your you're kind of ready to
use
um
type reagents where possible and
automation
and i think the more we can look at
bringing in automation into our
processes the more we can drive
standardization
and remove any kind of manual errors
that
are just inherently prone to manual
processes
all right thank you
next question
if there is a small artifact above the
tissue after cover slipping
does all of the tissue on the
digital image appear blurry or does this
just cause a few areas of blurriness
around the artifact does the scanner see
the artifact in the only scanned focal
plane or does it take more than one
focal plane to complete the slide scan
that is a great question
um
and again it's one that doesn't
necessarily have a straight yes or no
answer
and
so this is really going to be dependent
on the scanner and the scanner mechanism
so
some scanners will employ a technique
where they lay down a focus map
first so they will automatically detect
um
where your your tissue is and then they
will lay focus points on top of that
tissue to
kind of map that micro topography um
across the the tissue and be able to
then have a scan map that they it
follows so if one of those scan points
happens to be on a piece of debris or
artifact yes it can throw out the scan
map
and that could be the amount of
blurriness in that image would be
dependent on the size of the artifact
and kind of where that that next focal
point um or focus point
is within the the tissue
and other scanners will do a type of
real-time focusing or dynamic focusing
where
literia at every single
almost frame
and that's captured they're adjusting
the the focus and so you'll probably see
less of an impact
um of debris in that situation but again
if it's if the debris is at a different
focal plane and it's more prominent than
the tissue then if it's recognized as
tissue and it's focused on then it will
put the underlying tissue out of focus
and the other type is where you've got
um a 2d
image capture rather than a line scanner
and quite often they will focus again
for every 2d frame
and kind of an xy section
and
again depending on how many frames that
piece of debris would overlap into would
determine how much or if any of that
image is out of focus
but i hope that helps to
at least provide some guidance
great thank you next question
you mentioned single focus plan is
adequate for three to four micrometers
he stained sections
how about for three to four micrometer
sections for fish the same single focus
plan or need to use z stacks
interval one or two micrometer
okay um i think a great question again
it's going to depend a little bit
um on
[Music]
the the magnification and the numerical
aperture
um for the the objective lens that
you're using to scan
so typically speaking and again kind of
as a broad spectrum rule of thumb
and if you're capturing at
an equivalent of a 20 times or 40 times
magnification then you should be able to
capture
um
in a single focal plane at three or four
microns
if you go above that from a
magnification perspective and you're in
that that kind of 60x 100x or
you know 80 or 100 oil and type scenario
then you probably need to move to to z
stacks and yeah that interval of one to
two microns
and i think
when you're adopting digital pathology
and when you're looking at specific use
cases and i didn't really touch on this
during the presentation but it erases a
very good point
which will be to actually look at your
sample
types that you typically have within
your lab
and work out what the scanning
mechanism what would the standard
scanning process b for those slides
and so it'd be something to take into
careful consideration and then if you're
looking at fish and you're looking at
multiple fluorophores
within that tissue and you're
potentially looking at multiple z stacks
that's obviously going to give you a
multiplier on the scan time and the file
size that you have in that situation
and it's important then as you maybe
consider adopting digital pathology that
you take some of these things into
consideration because they're going to
impact on the throughput of your scanner
and the amount of slides that you could
typically scan within a normal
a normal day or a normal shift
i hope that helps
great thank you
um next question
what would you recommend for control
slides when you have multiple cases
attached to one control
that's an interesting one
so it's going to depend a little bit on
the image management and image viewing
system that you use and can that control
slide
be
kind of pinned
or
identified and associated them with your
different whether they're dosage groups
or
kind of reference reference slides maybe
is the
a better term to use so it's going to
depend more on the image management
system that you have there
um
and how your your slides are aggregated
into
into cases or groups or studies
depending on what you're looking at
and i think for that
there's probably some
kind of clever identification that you
could use within the barcode to identify
those groups and then ensure that your
control slide is always displayed in
your slide view or your slide tray or
grouping that you have for all of the
the dosage groups then that that would
be associated with
all right
and
it looks like we have time for one more
question
ideally slides would come right off the
cover slip and directly onto the scanner
is this going to be possible or what is
the minimum amount of drying in oven for
x minutes to minimize this time so that
images are available asap
um well i can see that this question
came in from from robert and robert
that's a great question um there are
solutions on the market today
where you have
your stainer and cover slipper
integrated
and then the stainless have integrated
drying ovens on them
um
and they take as little as five minutes
for
for fully drying your your cover slips
um and then they're already in a rack
that's compatible with scanners in which
case then you're just taking a rack out
of a scanner or out of a cover slipper
and popping it straight into a scanner
um again what i would recommend in this
is
to take that full holistic look at your
laboratory if you're considering
adopting digital pathology and identify
which are the pieces that you're keeping
which are the pieces where you are open
to change or optimization and if that is
at your staining or your cover slipping
stage and you're going to be able to
have a
maximized efficiency or optimized
efficiency at that point and remove some
of the hands-on time that may be a
consideration where you want to ensure
that your cover slipper rack
and functionality including that the
drawing
is compatible with your scanner of
choice
and we will wrap up with that final
question
thank you again olga for your time today
and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor leica biosystems for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time take care everyone
goodbye
you